ah and why why oh why will they put a
lever if it doesn't do anything i all
right
does not compute throw Sharon in ceiling
that's not good
I saw that I did it I were right there
it goes down after a while
that's what she said oh man those best
one in a long time
that was beautiful and
yeah still there that's what anyway
come on hint me something why why
sit down now I don't even know that's
maybe I can leave now
epic jump epic jump nope of course not
what does he do why doesn't it tell me
sad face I'm bringing you with me I
shouldn't know
come on please please pretty please
why do I keep walking in there why
okay let's go in here pull up the lever
or down maybe
come on
uh-huh stay
now now I promise it doesn't work come
man I'm running out of ideas whoa yeah I
need to end it here because otherwise
I'll never figure it out
I'll be right back the [ __ ] back to some
amnesia zombie escaped I know what to do
now
supposed to rob the dildo rub it thank
you
and then
no no no not there here good what what
penis above oh how the [ __ ] did I miss
that i watch someone else do this oh my
god
yeah anyway you're gonna move this
[ __ ] bookshelf and doesn't it make
sense that you pull here to move the
bookshelf just saying
anyway I'm not pissed or anything yeah
let's go and yeah now we can ski pretty
cocky new [ __ ] come at me bro I'm not
scared anymore
okay I'm round of oil I'm scared crap a
way to have a tank odd hoof you better
open yes thank you presents no problem
I've been here before
help [ __ ] you
oh I thought his face was at the wall I
thought it was pretty tiny penis anyway
not good bad
pretty cozy see you got to be optimistic
little ice is pretty [ __ ] cozy
alright find this nope nope nope nope
nope nope let's go hey oh I hate opening
these there's ah done uh
don't rape me bro please I just want to
go and say ah mu k oh why doesn't it
open oh but open up and open up with it
why doesn't it open
why didn't it open any [ __ ] [ __ ]
can do this Oh
closing door after me now now the
creeper part happen
can't be something amiss
to be Swift
why why do you hate me so much why do
you hate me
oh my they are calm oh this is so
[ __ ] come at me bro come at me I
[ __ ] dare you
so this as if he could break this ass
[ __ ] air
what is this
why are you impossible to
oh don't go anywhere
[ __ ] wimp cap sorry I don't even know
you can see me
what did you what did I ever do to you
meaning
it's so stupid
here's a poo bucket
so you something
why are you doing this to me why oh I
know no that can't be right
what we could try I guess maybe have to
pull that lever you know is that really
didn't do anything no I'm stuck
no I'm not
physics this is where you push
yes thank you get out of the way
I'm out of oil and I'm getting pissed at
this [ __ ] Mod full of witches and
penises
it's run for it I didn't weigh
where it's covered with abetting why
didn't you show up this time only the
first time of making sense
why do you hate me so much
okay let's just put things between us
apart and open this is this like the
freaking lever that didn't do anything
it is they're just [ __ ] with me right
for some
oh wait this is working good
that's great getting worried there
okay let's do it
sometime I picked the wrong room I'm
such a [ __ ]
now you don't open I might have to kill
something huh
the controls are so [ __ ] open oh man
oh I finally did it where the [ __ ] am i
what is this my in a nozzle
I think this is what an [ __ ] looks
like why I can't move anyway oh I have
to cross
that's fine pretty dark
I think oh this nope nothing there
why would they even do that I don't know
let's go I'm not on fire today
definitely not
we're breaking progress uh-huh
pretty fun
uh-huh
some oil would be fantastic right now
the door which I can't even see
uh-huh
what is this
I really can't see [ __ ]
uh-huh
another one of those probably doesn't do
anything as usual I did something holy
[ __ ] yeah stairs I really don't see
anything why he goes whoa ah water
let help I still don't see anything
oh there's a room down here how's it
doing
Oh what the [ __ ] was that oh my god oh
now a friend told me about this he was
like this weight for flying Jesus and I
guess that was flying Jesus whoa bad
Oh flying Jesus again
oh he's after me oh thank Jesus why
would you do this to me
oh man just don't do that again what is
up with this room there's nothing in
here something in the ground
I can barely [ __ ] see anything you
better not make any move on me sighing
Jesus
so
I can't see [ __ ]
all these places that has nothing in
them whoa
I went in here right yeah I'm surprised
I'm not insane yet this kid's got to
make sure I did
now we're getting okay let's get out of
here
please
I move this from here nope
we're definitely done here just flying
this is attacks back that was fun
not really but anyway
so yeah oh here we go
oil thank you I really needed that
let's break stuff oh I can't they're
just they're hovering make sense I mean
I have hovering bottles at my place -
everyone is hovering bottles
come on now here we go it's time to make
stuff but I'm missing something
am I missing why can't I use it that way
what freaking way do you want me to use
it
let's go there yeah turn all the fires
and these are
I have no way that what's going on
what is that okay I'm taking a break now
I don't even know if you can see me ah